- MY ULTIMATE CHICKEN SANDWICH?
- SUPER SPICY.
- BAM! IN MY MOUTH!
- DRIPPING
WITH FLAVOR.
- I'M A GUY.
- I DESERVE TO BE SATIATED.
- NONE OF THIS VEGAN
CHICK FOOD.
- I WANT TO EAT
WHERE I [bleep].
- YOU GOT A PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
- I WANT MY FOOD
MADE BY SOMEONE
WHO'S NOT AFRAID
TO OFFEND PEOPLE.
- INCLUDING ME.
- WELL, WHO ELSE IS GONNA MAKE
A CHICKEN SANDWICH
THIS DELICIOUS?
- PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T RACIST?
- I DON'T AGREE
WITH THEIR POLITICS,
BUT THAT HOT SAUCE
IS OFF THE CHARTS.
- I WANT A TOOTHLESS, BACKWATER
DUDE COOKING MY SANDWICH.
- LOOK, I DON'T THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND, THEY PUT PICKLES
ON THE CHICKEN,
IS THAT RACIST?
- I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT RACE I AM,
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THIS CHICKEN
SANDWICH IS DELICIOUS.
- LOOK, MY BROTHER'S GAY,
SO I DON'T EAT
CHIKK KLUB
IN FRONT OF HIM,
JUST LIKE I ASK HIM
NOT TO KISS
HIS BOYFRIEND IN FRONT
OF MY CHICKEN SANDWICH.
- I'LL TEXT MY BUDDIES, BE LIKE,
"WE GONNA GET CHIKK KLUB?"
THEY'RE LIKE, "ABSOLUTELY NOT,"
AND I'M LIKE, "SOLO MISSION."
- I LOVE WHO I AM,
WHERE I'M FROM...
I JUST LOVE CHIKK KLUB
SANDWICHES JUST A LITTLE MORE.
- CHIKK KLUB.
- MARRIAGE BETWEEN A MAN
AND A CHICKEN SANDWICH.
[chicken clucks]
- WE'RE GOOD.